احد اكبر تجمعات اللاجئين في افريقيا
بتلاجئا السودان ومع كل قصف يعكر سماءه
تتضاعف اعداد نازحيه وتوقعات امميه بفرار
مئات الالاف مفوضيه الامم المتحده قالت ما
لا يقل عن 75 الف شخص نزحوا داخليا بسبب
الازمه فيما بلغ عدد المشردين قرابه ثلاثه
ملايين الف شخص معظمهم في منطقه غرب
دارفور المضطربه بينما 37 الف شخص نزحوا
عبر مدينه نيالا وثلاثون الفا توجهوا
جنوبا الى النيل الابيض فالسودان لم يعد
ملاذا امنا هرب اخرون الى الخارج
التقديرات تشير الى ان عشرين الفا عبروا
الى تشاد وقد ترتفع الاعداد الى 100 الف
بحسب المنظمه الدوليه للهجره و14 اخرين
اتجهوا الى مصر وذا ت العدد لكن الى جنوب
السودان اما اثيوبيا فاستقبلت
3500 شخص ولاد بالفرار الى افريقيا الوسطى
1300 بينهم 500 طفل وامراه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات